uh our friend michael cohen donald
trump's former personal attorney
he seems to be putting his foot down and
saying hey guys either indict trump or
i'm out and i'm going to stop
cooperating and i have to tell you i
sympathize with michael cohen 100 so
let's go through what's going on there's
a good daily beast piece called
manhattan d.a star witness indict trump
now or i'm out the piece is by jose
paglieri
and it reads if manhattan prosecutors
don't indict former president donald
trump with the grand jury they've got in
the next nine days
the key witness investigators used to
build their entire case says he won't
help revive it in the future they're
talking of course about michael cohen
the new york lawyer trump used for years
as his families as his family companies
trusted consigliere told the daily beast
he's already wasted too much of his time
on a case that slowly and then suddenly
doesn't seem to be going anywhere
prosecutors only have until the current
grand jury's term expires on april 30 to
issue charges at which point they must
ask jurors who have already done this
for six months to continue hearing
evidence or call the whole thing off
and awkwardly make the entire
presentation all over again for another
23 jurors if this grand jury is let go
cohen won't play ball asked if he'd be
willing to sit down again with
investigators or testify at a future
trial against trump cohen responded with
utter exasperation no i've spent
countless hours 15 sessions including
three while incarcerated i provided
thousands of documents which coupled
with my testimony would have been a
valid basis for an indictment and charge
the fact that they have not done so
despite all of this i'm not interested
in any further investment of my time
i have to tell you this makes perfect
perfect sense now some people are mad at
michael cohen saying wait a second
you have the knowledge
you have the information
hell you're the one who actually was
found guilty
of crimes related to doing trump's
bidding and now you're going to bail but
i this make makes 100 sense to me
remember we have now learned about the
resignation of investigators
in an investigation into donald trump
why did the investigators resign
they resigned because they saw that
there was enough evidence not only to
charge trump but they felt to clearly
get convictions
and yet it didn't seem to them like
there was actually any political
interest in bringing forth charges
against donald trump
why are you sitting around
doing this type of work if it's not
going to go anywhere what there is a
torture technique
and or it's just a way to kind of uh
make people exasperated right and you
we've heard about this like when we talk
about
hard labor in prison over time in
history sometimes one thing that was
done is you you just have people break
rocks and then move them and then move
them back
and knowing that what you're doing is
going to go absolutely nowhere
is absolutely demoralizing and so i
understand the investigators saying what
are we just doing this for fun is this
just an academic exercise because there
seems to be no willingness to actually
charge donald trump they resigned and
michael cohen seems to be feeling
something pretty similar i've given you
everything i testified while
incarcerated i've provided documents i'm
giving hell i got in trouble for the
stuff that trump directed me to do which
was against the law
and it's going nowhere and the grand
jury is set to end on april 30th so
this is very clearly one of the most
blatant political non-prosecutions that
i've seen in the world of you know
national american politics cohen is at
this point understandably exasperated
multiple people around trump have gone
to prison for crimes they did either for
or in coordination with trump we've had
multiple investigations
what what are we doing we've seen
campaign finance violations we've seen
obstruction we've seen the removal and
mishandling of classified documents we
arguably have seen uh election fraud
conspiracy in at minimum in the state of
georgia and these are just the obvious
ones let's not even talk about the
multiple conspiracies elsewhere the rest
of america i think is now seeing
the
disenfranchisement that so many groups
have felt for a long time right i mean
the non-rich know about the two justice
systems minorities know about being
treated in a particular way by police
jews and muslims know about religious
discrimination remember in the united
states when we look at religious hate
crimes it's jews and muslims that are
primarily targeted we now are all seeing
exactly how this plays out wait so he
gets treated one way and everybody else
gets treated a different way yep that's
exactly what's going on
so i as much as the next guy would want
to see charges brought but i understand
why michael cohen is putting his foot
down how much more of his life has to be
devoted to testifying and giving
evidence uh and having lawyers himself
remember
um when it's not even clear that there's
really a willingness to bring charges so
we'll see what happens there's three
more days until this grand jury is done
and then we'll see what happens after
that as many of you know i'm a busy
person i don't always have the exact
correct nutritional plan for my meals
every single day and that's why i also
take a multivitamin and a couple of
supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals and my
probiotics and it's all from whole food
sources i drink it in the morning i know
i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning it when what time of day do i
need to take each one i just get it all
with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below